BRADY HARAN: I shall be
with you shortly.
Thank you everyone.
How are you all?
My name's Brady Haran, and I
make the Numberphile videos.
I also make several other
YouTube channels, which I
might talk about in a minute.
I'm not going to be here
for very long.
I guess this is kind of
a test run for me.
I want to see how a few things
are working with the webcam
and lights and things
like that.
I've been having all
sorts of problems.
And I'm also having a new
computer delivered, so to show
you just how live this is, if
the door knocks, I'm going to
be out of here very quickly
because I missed the delivery
yesterday and I don't want
to miss it again.
The main reason I'm here is
I want to tell you about
something like this that I'm
going to be doing tomorrow at
around the same time.
Except it won't be just me
sitting here, I'll be here
with Dr. James Grime, who's in
loads of Numberphile videos.
And we're going to be doing a
bit of a live thing where I'm
going to ask him questions.
But more to the point, I'm
hoping that you're going to
ask him questions.
So if you do nothing else,
please leave some comments
underneath this video with
questions for James and things
for us to talk about.
Especially in case you can't
make it tomorrow, I'll read
your questions here in the
comments and try and make sure
we cover some of that stuff.
Basically I just want to make
sure we've got something to
talk about from the start, so
please leave any questions.
I'll remind you again about the
James thing because that's
the most important thing that I
want you to take from this.
And we're going to be doing it
at 4:00 PM UK time, which is
11:00 AM on the East Coast in
America, 8:00 AM on the West
Coast in the US, and 2:30 AM
if you are in Adelaide,
Australia, where I'm from.
I always like to give things
in Adelaide time as well.
Shooting for that.
In the meantime, you can ask me
any questions quickly now.
I'm having a quick look at
some of your comments.
There's lots of them basically
saying hello.
So, hello.
Here we go.
"Did you hear about a French
podcaster who talked about
you?" No, I didn't.
"What do you think about
Russia?" I've never been to
Russia, but I would like to go
for Periodic Videos because--
Periodic Videos is my chemistry
channel for people
who don't know about it--
the periodic table obviously
has its birth in Russia.
So we do plan to go there
sometime and make some
Periodic Videos.
People are asking me about
numbers and mathematics.
That's probably not such a good
idea because I'm not a
mathematician or
a math expert.
Tomorrow James will be here,
that will be a good time to
ask some of those questions
perhaps.
I'm asked which one
is James Grime.
He's in the most Numberphile
videos.
You can go back and have
a look who he is.
He's really good value.
"How many do you have?" How
many channels do I have, I
guess that means.
I think there's about
12 channels.
Numberphile, Deep Sky Videos
, Periodic Videos, Sixty
Symbols, Nottingham Science,
Bibledex, Words of The World ,
Backstage Science, My Favourite
Scientists,
Philosophy File, PsyFile, did
I say Words of the World?
"Hey Brady, greetings
from Spain."
So the last video I put
up was the one about
statistics in football.
I live in the UK and I do call
football "football", although
I am from Australia, so I grew
up calling it soccer.
I've had a lot of comments about
that, so I thought I'd
discuss that as well.
A lot of people don't like
it when I call it soccer.
And I don't know, I think it's
kind of the right thing to do.
I said at the start of the
video, "It's football, but
some people call it soccer,"
and then I called it
soccer a few times.
Soccer obviously being a
shortening of Association
Football apparently.
And I think it's OK to call
it soccer in that context.
I mean a lot of Numberphile
viewers are American and a lot
are Australian.
And I think if I say soccer,
everyone knows what I'm
talking about.
And if I start staying football
all the time, some
people don't.
And they might get confused,
so I don't think there's
anything wrong with a few
"soccer's" in there amongst
the "football"s.
I know people feel passionately
about it.
But there you go.
And another thing I get asked a
lot about is the brown paper
in Numberphile videos,
so I thought I'd
quickly discuss that.
I've written a blog
about this.
My blog, if you ever want to
look it up, is called Periodic
Videos blogger or blogspot .
If you just google Periodic
Videos and blogger, you'll
find my blog.
And if you google Periodic
Videos and brown paper, you'll
find the blog that I
wrote about this.
And I always point
people to it.
But let me talk you quickly
through the brown paper.
Basically when I started
Numberphile, I knew there was
going to be a lot of writing
involved from the people in
the films, the mathematicians
and
scientists and other guests.
And I wanted to make that a
feature of the videos .
I considered blackboards, I
considered buying little
slates and chalkboards, because
I thought that might
be nice, but in the end I
thought that would be messy,
it wouldn't work very well.
There are lots of reasons
it wouldn't work.
When you wipe them out, they
look really messy unless you
clean them really nicely.
And in the end I kind
of abandoned that.
I hate whiteboards.
They also look pretty mucky
when you rub them off.
But also it's just, whiteboards
just remind me of
corporate conferences and school
and I don't really want
Numberphile to be like that.
Obviously you could do something
with electronic
tablets and whatnot but I
thought that might be a little
bit Khan Academy.
And I quite liked the
idea of brown paper.
I didn't like the idea of
white paper because--
and this is another reason
whiteboards aren't too good--
a really white background is not
very good for filming when
you're filming people's faces
and the whiteboard.
It becomes very difficult to
control certain aspects of the
picture while you're filming.
Whereas brown paper is
a bit nicer for that.
And I also just like the kind
of the rustic, rich,
ruggedness of the brown paper,
that kind of back of an
envelope, napkin type
feel that I like
Numberphile to have.
I like it to feel
very informal.
And I also really like the idea
of being able to keep the
artifacts afterwards.
Initially I was putting
them all onto Flickr.
And I still put a lot
of them onto Flickr.
If you look at the Numberphile
Flickr, you can go and look at
previous bits of paper
we've used.
I will say lately I've started
putting a few of them on eBay
for various reasons, to either
raise money for charity or to
raise a bit of extra money for
some of the things we do with
Numberphile that cost money.
I've got some here.
Here's a whole bunch of brown
papers from some previous,
some upcoming videos.
So I've started keeping them.
I used to throw them away after
they'd been scanned and
put onto Flickr.
And now I realize that some
people quite like them and
would like to keep them.
So I'm hanging on to
as many as I can.
Occasionally I'll give one away
or put one on eBay for
some reason, so keep an eye out
for that kind of thing on
Twitter and Facebook
and whatnot.
So anyway, there are
few other reasons I
quite like brown paper.
I won't go into them all now.
I know some people don't like
the noise of the markers on
the brown paper.
And we've changed the markers
since the start, because the
first markers we used were
a bit of a mistake.
And I also am trying
to do a bit more
with the sound editing.
I'll have a look at more of your
comments for a moment.
"Out of focus." That's
interesting.
I am experimenting with the
camera and I'm having a few
problems with the lights as
well causing flicker.
So if you want to leave
some more comments--
but any problems with the camera
at the moment, I'll be
looking back over this
video and trying to
sort out so, apologies.
It's a bit of a learning
curve.
You guys are helping me learn.
"Are you sponsored by a brown
paper company?" No, but if you
know one, put them in touch.
I'm being asked things about
Planck length and
the speed of light.
And again that's one
for the people I
interview more than me.
Sorry about the focus,
I'll work on that.
Then again if you watch my
videos you're probably used to
things being out of
focus, aren't you?
"What about a channel about
computer science?" That's
something that some thought
has been given to.
"Australia has many things
called football." I do call it
football at home by the way.
Or, home, now that
I live in the UK.
"Greetings from Israel."
Hello, Israel.
If you watch my Bibledex
channel, we actually went and
filmed a whole bunch of
videos in Israel.
Which I really enjoyed.
I really enjoyed it there.
"How do you manage so many
channels?" I don't know.
It's hard work.
"What time will the stream
start tomorrow?"
I'm glad you asked.
And again that's the point of
this whole video, that I'll be
here tomorrow with
James Grime.
Hopefully more in focus
after I've played with
the camera some more.
That's tomorrow, Valentine's
Day, yes I'm spending
Valentine's Day with James.
We're also going to be making a
bunch of Numberphile videos
beforehand.
And then we'll be doing this.
So we might be able to tell
you about what we'd filmed
beforehand so you'll have
a bit of an exclusive.
Tomorrow, Valentine's Day,
February 14, 2013.
4:00 PM in the UK.
You can do the math for
most other people.
Notice I called it math there
for the Un-American viewers.
That's 11 AM on the East Coast
in US, AM on the West Coast,
and 2:30 AM in Adelaide.
And a reminder, if you don't get
to watch live, you'll be
able to watch the recording
at your convenience.
And also if you want to ask a
question, you can put the
question in this comment section
and I'll be reading
through this later on with my
hand over my eyes, judging by
some of the comments.
And I'll take some of the
better comments and
interesting questions and throw
them around with James.
I'll just refresh the comments
here from you guys.
"I'm from India." Hello.
We have also filmed in India.
If you watch Periodic Videos,
the chemistry channel, we've
done a whole bunch of
films in India.
"Have you ever been to Austria?"
My brother-in-law is
Austrian, and I have been
to Austria many times.
And I've been to his home
village of San Johann in the
Tirol several times, where he
and my sister ski very well
and I ski very, very badly.
"Can you please do more
Philosophy File videos?" I
bumped into the people from
philosophy just today and we
were discussing that.
We'll try and get some more
soon, hopefully later in the
year, maybe.
It just depends on time
and other factors.
But I do enjoy doing the
philosophy ones.
And stay subscribed to that
one, because there will be
more coming.
My fish doesn't have a name.
People who come obviously
call him Nemo because
he's a clown fish.
But I haven't actually given
this one a name.
But he is a very hardy,
very hardy fish.
He endures a lot.
Some people are saying
the focus is fine.
I don't know, I did notice it
dropping in an out a bit, but
I'll go back and have a look.
I'm trying my best, all
this technology.
"Do I meet up with people at
Nottingham University with the
professors who you do the videos
with?" someone says.
We have done one video which had
Professor Poliakoff, from
chemistry, Professor Merrifield,
who was in Deep
Sky Videos and Sixty Symbols,
Professor Moriarty, and
Professor Copeland.
And I had the four of
them sitting there
like in a firing squad.
And I think we did that on the
Periodic Videos channel or the
Sixty Symbols channel.
I can't remember which, but
it wasn't that long ago.
I'll put the link if I remember
in the description
for this video when this video
becomes an archived video.
But you can go and
watch those guys.
And we have got plans to do more
this year, which is half
the reason I'm sort of
testing this camera.
My computer has arrived,
I think.
I'll be right back.
Here's part one.
He's just gone back to his truck
to get the other part.
I shall return.
I'm very excited.
There we go.
You might be able to tell from
the box what it is, but I'm
not going to discuss it because
I don't want to start
one of those conversations.
I'm so sorry about that.
Those are the joys of live
broadcasting, but I wasn't
going to miss that delivery
after missing it yesterday.
I'll have a quick look
at more comments.
For those who have just joined
us and were greeted by a blank
screen, I'm sorry, I was just
taking delivery of a computer
that I've been waiting
for for a few days.
This is a bit of a test run
that I've been doing--
sorry I'm a bit puffed
out now from
running after that computer--
this is a bit of a test run.
We're doing a live hangout
tomorrow with Dr. James Grime.
He'll be sitting here with me,
if you want to ask any
questions you can join
us tomorrow.
You can put in some
questions now.
Tomorrow, 14th of February,
4:00 PM UK time, 11:00 AM
Eastern US, 8:00 AM Western
US, 2:30 AM Adelaide time.
I'm just going to update
the comments.
"Putting comments here is like
dropping rubber ducks into a
fast flowing stream." I
know what you mean.
"I like the Eiffel Tower." You
probably joined and were just
looking at the Eiffel
Tower on the wall.
Sorry about that.
"He's getting a new computer."
"He's getting it from a
delivery guy." I'm truly
sorry about that.
"Mac or PC?" Let's not go
there at the moment.
"Mac or PC?"
"What you up to fish?" I did
leave you alone with the fish.
I'm really sorry about that,
I'm just finding out if
there's anything else here
I can answer for you.
"Where did you complete
school?
England or Australia?" I
completed school in Australia.
If you watch Periodic Videos, we
did a film where I actually
went back and met my Chemistry
and Physics teacher, called
Mr. Dinowski.
That's a video you can watch.
"Livestream the un-boxing." I'm
not going to do that, I'm
not even going to set up the
computer for a couple of days.
I'm so worried and intimidated
by the idea of trying to get
my whole life from one computer
to another that you
wouldn't want to
watch it live.
"Greetings from Finland."
I won't be doing an
un-boxing video.
"Is zero an even number?" Now
I have said that I'm not a
mathematician, but I can tell
you that zero is an even
number, because we did
a video about that.
I think I'm back at the
end of the comments.
I think that's everything
for now.
"Greetings from Germany.
Do you speak German?" Nein.
"Greetings." I like how everyone
puts greetings from
their country.
"Do you have a pet?" Yes.
I do have a pet.
I have my fish, and I have
a dog that is not
very good at coming.
Hang on.
Lulu.
Come here, come here, come
here, come here.
This is my pet.
Come here.
This is Lulu.
She's a retired racing
greyhound.
What's that?
She has appeared in several
videos for the
eagle-eyed among you.
The first yahtzee video
she ate the number
Spaghetti at the end.
Good girl.
"When is Phil coming back?
I'm seeing Professor
Moriarty on Friday.
And we're planning to film some
Numberphile and Sixty
Symbols videos.
Probably more Sixty Symbols ones
I think we have planned.
Remember the main point of the
comments section here as well
is to, even if you watch this
later on and you're not
watching it live, put some
comments for James tomorrow so
we've got something
to talk about.
"Have you ever played
Minesweeper?
What are your best times?" I
have played Minesweeper quite
a long time ago and I can't
remember any of my times.
"What was your favorite subject
in school?" I liked
maths and Physics
and Chemistry.
But also liked English.
I always wanted to
be a journalist.
I always wanted to be newspaper
journalist and a
writer, so I also really
liked English.
"How long have you been
interested in number facts?" I
think I've always been
interested in number facts.
"What was your first job?" My
first job was a journalist for
a newspaper in Australia.
"Are you ginger, strawberry
blond, or mouse brown?" You
can decide that one.
"What are the specs for your
computer?" I can't even
remember, I ordered that
about a month ago.
"Please make a video, talk to
the astronomers about the
Great Attractor." I think that's
something we will do
for Deep Sky Videos or Sixty
Symbols quite soon, because
I'm quite keen on the idea
of that one as well.
"Greetings from Chile."
Where we might be
traveling later this year.
"What did you do before these
videos?" I used to work for
the BBC as a video journalist
making films for the news.
And before that I worked
in newspapers.
"What got you into video
journalism?" I said I worked
for the BBC.
When I first worked for the BBC,
I worked for the website
and I was doing lots of stories
and things for the
website that they quite liked.
And they thought that I should
learn how to make films about
them as well so what I was doing
could also go onto the
news and television programs.
So they taught me to be
a video journalist.
"What is that golden orb behind
you?" I'll put it out
just a little bit.
It's actually a globe
of the moon.
Like an Earth globe, except
its the moon.
And it's like a vintage antique
one so it was made
before they knew what
the other side of
the moon looked like.
Because obviously the moon
always has one face pointing
towards the Earth pretty much.
And for a long time we didn't
know what the other side
looked like until we got
probes around there.
So when you turn that globe
around, it's like
a map of the moon.
You turn the back around and
there's a big blank area where
it was unknown.
Which of course is very
well-known now.
I'll do one more refresh
of these comments.
248.
"You should do a video with
Minute Physics." Well I have
done some videos with
Minute Physics.
If you have a look at a video
I did on Sixty Symbols, I
actually interviewed Henry from
Minute Physics and talked
all about how he makes
his films.
And Henry from Minute Physics
also appears in our favorite
number videos.
"What football team do you go
for?" I actually support
Liverpool for various reasons,
although I live about 10
minutes-- no, I don't I live
about a five minutes walk from
Nottingham Forest's
home ground.
"Would you like to do a video
with V-Source?" I have done
some videos with V-Source.
He has actually sat
in this very chair
in one of the videos.
He's a very busy man but
he makes very good
videos, very popular.
"What university did you go to?"
I went to the University
of South Australia in Adelaide,
where I'm from,
doing journalism.
But I didn't finish the degree
because partway through the
degree I was offered a
cadet-ship at a newspaper I
wanted to work for and
I took that job.
"Have you been drunk
yesterday?
You look a bit hungover and
sleepy." No, this is just
unfortunately what
I look like.
I always look a bit sleepy
because I don't sleep.
I'm too busy making videos.
"Are you aware of internet
cultures like Reddit, 4Chan?"
I'm aware of Reddit, I really
enjoy browsing Reddit.
I'm aware of 4Chan, but it's
not one that I use.
"What kind of fish are in your
tank?" It's a clown fish.
There will be more videos coming
on my channel Foodskey
which has stopped for
quite a while, which
is about food science.
But there's a few more
in the works, so keep
an eye out for that.
I don't think I'll be starting
a yoga channel.
Hello to everyone
in Lithuania.
"Would you ever kill someone to
maximize your math skills?"
No, I wouldn't do that.
"Do you spend more time in the
university--" and other places
I assume-- "filming, or at home
editing the videos?" More
time is spent on the editing
overall definitely.
That's a more time consuming
activity.
But sometimes when you're
going to film in other
countries, obviously, you spend
a lot of time traveling
and getting to the
things you film.
When you do those sort of films,
then you spend less
time editing and more time
traveling and filming.
"Where can I find Numberphile
merchandise like shirts and
stuff?" Funny you should say
that, because a friend of mine
runs a business making shirts
and things like that.
And I've been talking
to him about--
I know a lot of YouTubers have
shirts and stuff like that and
it's something we're starting
to think about.
So if you think it's something
you might be interested in
leave some comments and ideas of
things that you might like
and we might sort
something out.
"Are you musical?" I am not.
I have no musical ability.
Well, I like some music,
I'm going out
to see a band tonight.
"How long is this video
going to be?"
That's a good question.
It's too long already
isn't it?
Especially with my little
interlude in the middle, which
I'm really sorry for.
Thank you for everyone who
hung around despite that.
There's a lot of comments now.
"Have you ever thought
about setting up
Tumblrs?" Yes, I have.
I should do that, I really like
the Tumblrs I've looked
at and it's something
I haven't done yet.
You've just reminded me that's
something I want to look into
doing with all that
spare time I have.
Thank you for everyone
who is saying nice
things about the channels.
And thank you for contributing,
everyone who's
not saying such nice things.
"Do you have a list of all your
YouTube channels?" If you
go to my blog, which is called
Periodic Videos, so go to
Periodic Videos blogger,
or Periodic
Videos blogspot on Google.
On the right hand side of the
blog there's like a little
link saying, "Here's a link to
all my channels." And you can
click on that.
And when this video becomes an
archived video and it's not
live anymore, I'll go into the
description and put a list as
well for people who want to
check out other channels.
Yes it is hard work,
running them all.
"Greetings from the
Netherlands." Greetings back
to the Netherlands, and I'm
sorry about featuring the goal
that cost you the World Cup in
our last Numberphile video.
A lot of people have said it
really hurt to see that and I
understand, I understand.
"Do you know Minute Physics?"
Yes, I do know Minute Physics,
as I've said before.
He makes excellent videos,
of course.
"Would you do an AMA, Ask Me
Anything, on Reddit?" I would,
but I don't think I'm
particularly famous enough, I
don't think it would be
very well attended.
I don't think it would
be a smash hit.
"What software do you use?" I
edit on Avid Media Composer,
which I usually like.
But I don't like when
it crashes.
"What camera equipment?" My main
camera at the moment is a
Sony Z7, but I'm about to buy
another one, so any advice is
gratefully received.
"Why do you have such a gorgeous
accent?" That's not a
question I've ever been
asked before.
It's a hybrid Australian
and British accent.
"Do you like Minecraft?"
I'm not a Minecrafter.
But at Christmas it was shown to
me, and I'm very intrigued
by it and it looks like
something that, at a time in
my life when I had time for sort
of games and activities
like that, I would have
really liked.
I think it looks really cool.
I can see why people
are really into it.
And I actually have some
Minecraft ideas of things I'd
like to do with Numberphile
videos and things like that.
"Brady, I saw your video
on sand--" which was on
Sixty Symbols --
"that person said you can get
work experience there.
I can't find anything on the
website, can you help?"
Unfortunately I can't help,
because I don't actually know
where on the website
these are.
I think I would just do what all
of you guys would do and
google and find things out.
The guy who was in the video, a
guy called Steven Goldfarb,
has actually gone into the
comment section on that video,
which is one of the most recent
Sixty Symbols videos if
you haven't seen it, and he
wrote an answer to someone
else who asked that comment.
And it had a lot to do
talking to people at
universities and things.
So go and have a look in the
full comment section under
that video and some light may
be shed on the problem.
"Do you own a different shirt?"
Yes, I do own a
different shirt.
This is my favorite
shirt, though.
It is clean, it's clean every
time I wear it, I promise.
Yes, we will do a Numberphile
about imaginary numbers.
"Where are you now?" I'm
in my office at home.
"Have you ever shot a
gun?" Yes, I have.
Hello, everyone in Poland.
Someone said they missed
the first 17 minutes.
You didn't miss much, you mostly
missed me going and
picking up a computer
from the front door.
But at the end of this video,
when I shut it all down, I
think YouTube will process it
and do whatever happens, and
then it will become live
and you can enjoy that.
Someone says they'd like to see
more Bibledex, which is
something I don't
often see on my
mathematics and science videos.
And actually I filmed some
Bibledex stuff today, because
of the news with the
Pope resigning.
I thought it was a good
opportunity to go and ask some
of the theology experts and
academics and religion experts
about what the Pope's all about,
and what they think
about the resignation.
And hopefully I'll be popping
something onto the Bibledex
channel soon because obviously
I don't do many videos for
that anymore, now that we've
done a video about every book
of the Bible.
Some of these questions I don't
understand and I'm not
going to read them, because
they're probably some joke I
don't get, and I'm going to
make a fool of myself.
"Are you on Facebook?" Well
Numberphile is on Facebook, as
is a lot of my channels.
Usually in the video
descriptions I include
Facebook addresses if you want
to go and follow there.
And I do put extra stuff on
Facebook that you won't find
in the video so much.
"How do you get to do videos
with the people at Opta?" You
ring up and you ask.
And sometimes people say yes,
and sometimes they say no.
But you never know
until you ask.
"Did you attend Nottingham?"
No, I did not.
I do a lot of work with the
University of Nottingham, but
I grew up in Australia, very
far away from Nottingham.
"I'd love to see you do a video
with Vihart." I have
done a couple of collaborations
of a sort with Vihart.
I was in her video about number
two, and she made a
video for me about
tetrahedral dice.
And she's also in my favorite
number videos.
And hopefully maybe we'll do
some other things sometime.
I do talk to her occasionally.
She's obviously a busy
lady as well.
"What does C.G.P. Grey look
like?" You know I
can't answer that.
"What do you usually eat?"
"Do people recognize you?"
Not incredibly often, but
occasionally it happens, usually
at strange times.
I'm not going to give you
a walk around my house.
"Are you interested in hiring
an editor so that you have
more free time?"
I do need help.
"Do you like Twitter?"
It's OK, I waste a
lot of time on Twitter.
You can follow me on Twitter
@PeriodicVidoes or
@Numberphile, depending on which
aspect of my personality
you wish to follow.
"Will you be present in the live
chat tomorrow?" Yes, I
probably will be.
I'll be with James, trying to
make sure it all goes smoothly
and asking him questions if
you guys don't ask enough.
Somehow I think you will ask
enough, though, judging by the
response today.
So a reminder, for those who've
just joined us, for the
final time, tomorrow,
Valentine's Day, February 14,
I'll be here again.
This time it won't just be me
waffling and reading my screen
and picking up a computer
from the front door.
I'll be here with Dr. James
Grime, who's the guy that's in
the most Numberphile
videos of anyone.
And we'll be talking
about whatever you
want us to talk about.
Leave some suggestions here
under this video, or just come
back tomorrow.
It will be at 4:00 PM UK time,
11:00 AM if you're on the East
Coast in the US, 8:00 AM on the
West Coast in the US, and
2:30 AM if you are from
Adelaide, Australia.
I don't know.
I could do this all day,
but I guess we have to
stop at some stage.
Thank you very much for everyone
who has put questions
and comments, good and bad.
This has been interesting
and fun for me.
I don't know what it's been
like for you because I can
only see what you write.
But if these things go well, and
you guys show an interest,
we'll try and do more of
them, because it's fun.
And I like you to see people
as unedited as possible.
That's why I make my videos the
way I do, and you can't
see us more unedited
than live.
It's been fun.
Thank you very much.
Cheers.